[Music]
yak is back
you know tick tock and yik yak should
make a combo app don't do that
called tic tac
[Applause]
you know there's no bone in here
after a four year hiatus really it's
been four years
since yik yak so yik yak was like cody
thought it was 50. yeah [ __ ] you cody
thought he went to college 10 20 years
ago
i saw some tweet that was like gen z
will never know what yik yak is yes they
will yeah but also it wasn't it gen z
four years ago
uh yeah i guess yeah yeah wouldn't would
gen z it was kind of well i mean like i
think i don't know it was basically like
4chan for
like
colleges right and like greek life i
i've never used it so i don't know
i never used it either but
it was all over twitter so crazy ass way
to lay i've never used this [ __ ] i was
like 4chan for 18 years
but i knew it was like it shut down
because
people got bullied and [ __ ] on there
right is that why i shut down yeah i
always i always heard like j uh
yikkiak was weird too because people use
it to like meet up and
do
put out weird feelers for things like i
want to be
tied up and spanked yeah called a little
[ __ ] bone basically the way it works is
that it it's like an anonymous message
board within five miles of wherever you
are
so like if you're on a college campus
then it just becomes like gossip girl
for
and like we had some [ __ ] like that when
i was in college it was called juicy
campus
yeah and eventually got shut down
because of bullying and like it like
ruined people's lives it was [ __ ]
crazy did you ever give up
juicy goss
no i would like search my own name on
there sometimes
oh there it is right there
juicy campus that's crazy
wow that's nuts yeah that brings back
[Music]
weird memories
yeah so like
so this [ __ ] has been a thing for a
while
and so that's what yik yak was but i
just think it's funny because now that
that's like back
if you're not on a college campus and
it's just like normal
yeah just citizens of a city yeah it's
like an anonymous message board it's
[ __ ] like this is it sus to suck you on
dick if you can pull on it and milk your
own prostate then
that's the question go ahead man do what
you want to do yeah milk it dude milk
milk your own prostate brother milk your
bone man
well i was in junior high there was a
forum it was a lot smaller so
pretty much everyone had something
posted about them
i remember i found out about it super
late and i found a post with my name i
remember having like a insane anxiety i
had like 60 comments or something i
couldn't fathom that many people
like just saying something about me i'm
like what the [ __ ]
and
it was a mixture of
that guy is so [ __ ] short
and uh he has nice eyes
okay
your eyes your eyes
your eyes i like his eyes i like his
eyes i like his eyes your eyes your eyes
your
yeah so you know that's better than you
know what most people would get at least
on juicy campus it was bad dude it was
like this girl sucked every dude's dick
and
five mile radius hell yeah yeah it was
just brutal you might just logging on
there just seen a whole bunch of [ __ ]
made
yeah this girl straight up lies this
girl just [ __ ] her pants and then like
you know [ __ ] a bunch of dudes with the
[ __ ] in her butt and then threw up in my
mouth and yeah cody is a micro penis
what no he's got 5 000 uploads you post
a picture of your dick
with your name like it's not small no
guys i'm the verified cody it's actually
me it's not micro but it's close lol
[ __ ] mid penis dude hell
my college was uh
it was like a commuter school so like
damn near everyone drove so i feel like
the campus social structure was just so
strange because you could be a freshman
but there'd be like [ __ ] 10 guys who
work at like a finance firm be like oh
yeah i'm here to take a few classes it's
like you could it always felt like you
were at work never got like a school
yeah
and like nobody really knows each other
and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah i feel like
our ours would have just been like
job postings yeah juicy campus um
does anyone know if uh
blah blah is hiring shut up nerd you're
in my econ class
you stink yeah and so apparently
like luke found out who brought brought
it back i guess some company
bought the rights
to redevelop
redevelop yik yak
oh we don't say anything
you loop yeah so they got a bunch of
like university apps
bought the rights from square who had
like acquired the engineering team or
something like that yeah they bought the
rights to relaunch it
and they relaunched it
and started like capitalizing off
the traffic of people being like oh my
god by like i don't know what they're
doing how they're tying it into you loop
services but they haven't yet but they
will inevitably yeah i think they will
luke did you say you found out that um
the president
has like a track record of just trying
to
restart old apps
so it looks like they're product manager
not their president got it i don't know
if it's a company effort but their
product manager has a few apps that are
like
trying to mimic other things and that's
how we were able to
connect the two because he uses all the
same ui for everything nice
yeah i
i was working with my production
assistant alex and
he logged into only fans i i
on jesus christ i've never
logged onto only fans and i just he has
an account well because we had this like
idea for a video but it didn't really
pan out but part of it was making only
fans account and so he he logs in in
front of me
and he's like oh wow it looks just like
twitter
and i said the most
nerd engineering thing like oh it's
because bootstrap oh yeah he just like
looked at me like huh
and i just you know
i like how
when the engineer slips out it's like
this
very it's like pulling out your micro
penis
oh it's because bootstrap
i felt myself get four inches smaller
when i said that
he's like oh you're a [ __ ] dweeb
you're a dweeb little [ __ ] boy it
looked exactly like twitter it was
which i think is genius and it's weird
like a lot of the postings they're not
like overtly sexual yeah you can just
like cruise through that [ __ ] like it's
just news
like some podcasts do it as like a meme
like oh you can listen to our podcast on
only fans but i think it's
it's gone past like parody
where it's like legit but
yeah anyway and so go to some
testimonials because i i can only
imagine it's just gonna end up exactly
like it did or like any of these end up
which is just vicious bullying
so go to like testimonials of old yik
yak users old yik yak
question
do you remember the app yik yak i was
like i don't know if you all remember
the app yik yak
where people could kind of just post
like whatever the [ __ ] they want and if
you're in their general vicinity you'll
like
see it
um someone uh made a bomb threat
um
to our school
the whole school was evacuated yeah
bomb threat yep
yeah that's pretty much
what i see happening with that yeah
also the [ __ ] out whatever they did
to relaunch it they got to fire their
team and re-hire engineers yeah it just
doesn't work
well as soon as you mention that it just
makes me think that it's like two
capped instances of like an you know an
amazon aws server
and someone who doesn't really
understand how to connect yeah all the
different products yeah so now i just
picture everyone's phone numbers and
emails just on like some
loose
[ __ ] s3 storage or something yeah
yeah just something
dumb as hell
so you should probably
delete your account
i will honestly yeah
you